hi everyone thank you for taking the
time to view the longer version of the
conference talk on small box
cryptography this is a joint work with
ibrahimovic and daniel bricks
what is the biggest open problem in
cryptography there are several worthy
candidates and there's definitely no
right answer but one candidate that we
feel should be obser should be of
commendable interest is the provable
security of alias the simple reason is
that it's used every day and everywhere
so given its ubiquitous usage
let's look at what is aes
well if you write down aes in its full
glory
it looks a bit messy
but we theoreticians love a good
abstraction and we have done just that
by abstracting aes away into something
called as a substitution permutation
network
so some spn uh in short um is a is
basically a sequence of structured
rounds where you have three steps a key
addition step a substitution step and a
permutation step
um
and
the only piece in this puzzle that is
non-linear and also the source of
hardness is the s box
and also aes inspired as a whole region
of popular ciphers which follow the same
design
which brings us to the question can we
prove security
unfortunately we cannot at least not
unconditionally on without proving p
versus np
um
but there are some results under some
restricted type of attacks
but we want to be ambitious can we prove
it secure in some idealized model or
assumption
unfortunately we hit a roadblock because
it's unclear how to use this how to
model this s box because that is the
only source of hardness and it is also
very small my design because you need
aes to be efficient
um
and
also there is no sound theory
on hardness uh that we can achieve by
iterating something that's so small or
simple like an s box or multiple rounds
or at least that was the case until this
work
which brings us to small box
cryptography and i'm going to tell you
this right now
so it is a mixture of proofs and
hardness conjectures
the former is something we like
uh the latter is something that we need
unless we solve p versus np and take
home a million dollars
it consists of
three steps which we can apply to
a lot of the primitives including uh and
we do it for the sp and aes setting and
also prg or a stream cipher the first
step is basically a traditional reduce
run proof
uh and
the second step is a hardness
amplification which could be possibly
provable on
and in the case of spn it is
provable if you know the key schedule
the third step is the conjecture part of
the puzzle which is
uh called the big to small conjecture
which essentially is the one-way
function equivalent of this new branch
of crypto called small box crypto
and the biggest
gain from this is that
everything is uh
um specified it explains uh existing
results and hopefully will guide new
designs
um and we also derive precise
quantitative bounds with explicit
dependence on number of runs and what we
achieve is something that's strong but
definitely more conservative than actual
the real world choices
which brings us to the case study of spn
so what is our result um
so when we use the most aggressive dick
to small conjecture we get the following
rounds um so bounce
sorry the rounds and bounce are
definitely uh tongue twister here
we get epsilon is equal to two to the
negative eight r over three security in
all rounds
which is actually pretty respectable we
get one over 100 million security for 10
rounds which is what aes does and pretty
much uh two to the negative 64 which is
excellent uh in 24 rounds uh security
and this all of this is for a random s
box
and this works with any linear p box
subject to the small caveat as long as
the inverse has no zeros
so what we get is an almost real aes
and it we believe this is good because
it guides future designs and it's
quantitative and everything is pretty
uh neatly specified there is no
uncertainty
so let's look at
and contrasting small box crypto with a
traditional crypto which we call big box
so big box crypto has this box or a hard
object which is at least security
parameter big so we typically have these
assumptions or these idealized models uh
using a random oracle ideal cipher
general random permutation generic group
so on and so forth
the big issue is that it does not
capture the real world symmetric crypto
because the abstraction that happens
when we use these big boxes too coarse
so that some of the most interesting
parts like in s box you lose the entire
quality there and when we actually have
very small drones we actually don't get
any quantitative bounds that's
meaningful uh from traditional uh crypto
so
what does traditional crypto
do when analyzing spf well it simply
replaces the entire substitution
permutation structure with a big
permutation pipe
but the problem is that we really can't
call it the substitution permutation
number because there's no substitution
happening
uh so
we call it key alternating cipher
now the security is proved
in uh
the
we prove the security uh in the in the
random
permutation model which is the big box
equivalent
um but
what would we get is that even one
ground is secure the famous ivan
mansurda cipher
but the question remains is it enough
actually to bring practice to theory and
the answer is that it does not appear to
be sufficient
so what are the problems with the big
books
we abstract away the spn structure which
is sort of the heart of the design and
with this big box of a permutation and
we lose structure
and it's quite difficult to improve
these implement these from big random
big grand permutation
and most existing candidates um
are never ideal so we need this ideal
functionality from this random
permutation but
the spn for example is never ideal
and why is spn better than any other
communication so what guides the choice
of the permutation is also a big
question
and
the proof can be sort of vanished when
we look at any concrete implementation
and the predicate number of rounds is
actually too low so we know that no one
round sp in etc and in fact it has been
shown by sequence of works um that the
exact security of key alternating cipher
increases with the number of rounds but
all of this work is again in the random
permutation model where we use
monolithic random permutation but
there's again some kind of a disconnect
but
the main thing is that there are no
meaningful at these quantitative bounds
for exact security
on dependent on the number of rounds
with real sps
which was actually implemented
so what
is our selling point how do we sell this
to
the practitioners
we have an spn
and we have 2 to the negative 8 r over 3
security in our bounce we will uh in our
rounds we will derive that in just a few
slides
which
i think would delight practitioners
on the other hand something which is
used in the big box
it's a whole bunch of question marks in
the security we don't know what the
security that's a function of number of
rounds and we don't know how to
implement or what is a good permutation
file which would leave
the practitioner scratching their heads
so now let's open up the small box and
figure out how we actually divide the
two to the negative eight r over three
bound
as we saw before small box photography
is a mixture of
proofs and hardness conjectures it's
three steps
so let's tackle the first step which is
done in the big
big box one
and
it's also called as domain extension
so how do we do this
we let's these are the parameters for an
spn
we ignore the actual values
uh for aes and we model the s box as a
publicly available random permutation
because it is also the only source of
hardness
and the best possible security would be
something like 2 to the negative n
clearly when n is equal to a this does
not make sense but we all think n is at
least security parameter for now
so the traditional hardness
questions that we are asked is what is
the minimum number of accounts are for
sp and security
to this end we will use the results of
cogniti at all where they have shown
that uh any three three round linear spn
has a security uh which is of double
which is big big of w squared q squared
by two to the n
and we will use this result
and combine this with the step number
two which is the hardness amplification
step which is also again done in the big
box work
and the idea here is that if i take the
same thing and run it repeatedly for
multiple runs we amplify the security
and this could be unconditional with
independent keys as shown by the model
at all
but what is it in the context of
spn the ideal hardness amplification the
dream result is basically to say that if
i have if i can breaking break one
instance in t comma epsilon hardness
then i can break c such independent
instance the key word being independent
in the same time t and epsilon to the c
but
it uh it has been shown that in its full
generality the stream hardness
amplification result is uh likely to be
false
but it seems true for most practical
instantiations and it's probably true in
many information theoretic settings
including the cascading of block ciphers
as shown by modern at all when we assume
independently
so what do we mean by a cascade of an
spf so when we have a cipher e1 e2 and
we want to cascade it we basically apply
the output of e1
uh as an input to e2
so we can also do the same thing for the
same cipher e where we do c cascading
where we cascade the e itself c times
and this
requires the keys to be independent in
theory but in practice we have something
known as a key schedule
so what does the model at all work give
us it gives us that if i have q comma
epsilon security of e e cascade at c
times is q comma two to the two epsilon
whole thing raised to the c secure
so now when we apply it to a three long
three round linear spn
we get 3c round linear spm which is q
comma q squared uh over two to the n
everything raised in c security now this
is unconditional with independent keys
and otherwise can we can only conjecture
it
so what we achieve is an amplified
security for the same running time
of the adversary that's mounting an
attack
and but know that all of this is still
only meaningful in the big big box world
now
we have done the first two steps which
brings us to the magic ingredient
of big to small conjecture
and obviously because of being a
conjecture it definitely needs further
study but before we go into this big to
small conjecture it makes sense
to prepare for magic
magic cannot happen uh imei
immediately at least not in the
cryptography world so we need to prepare
it
so what we do is we replace the number
of q our query is q by running time g so
this is the time that we want the
attacker uh to
be up about it by
so we get 3c round linear sp and this
t comma
t squared over 2 to the n everything
goes to c security
now
i want fixed
t to be the value that we want at the
end so just just for us to remember that
nothing changes
but note that the epsilon value that you
see here is actually dependent on t
and that is a problem for us so we will
remove the dependence of t in the
security epsilon by
placing explicit lower bound on the size
n so what we will say is that
well
if n is greater than 20 log t then we
get that any 3c non-linear spn is 2
is 2 to the negative 0.9 c and
secure
and
what we get
is a new security definition t comma 2
to the negative 0.9 n to the c secure
and when we put r is equal to three c
which is the number of rounds we get r
round uh s
r round uh
spn is t comma two to the negative point
three r in secure provided n is zero and
twenty log t
now with this done let's move on to the
the conjecture part of the puzzle
so how do we go from the big to small
conjecture so what this is what we have
we just proved it any around our linear
spn is
uh two to the negative point pr and
secure provided n is greater than 20 log
in
but what we really want is r round
secure
security if n is equal to a
so when you plug in n is equal to 8 here
we get
t comma 5.28 to the negative r secure
but
there is a discrepancy
we have n is equal to 8 and n is equal
to n is greater than 20 log t clearly
both of these cannot be
the same but let's just assume it that's
the conjecture part of the puzzle
because we need some crazy assumption
anyway and this is essentially big to
small conjecture
but we need to be a bit careful because
there can be brute force attacks because
when i reduce n
i have smaller key length and when we
use key schedule uh there could be some
brute force attacks but we i'll refer
you to the paper for details because
it's not really a big deal in practice
so what is the philosophy
big to small philosophy
we have a natural construction that
makes sense for any n
so we get t comma epsilon of n security
but only if n is greater than l of t in
the
um
uh that's what we get and clearly the
proof breaks down if n is too small but
then we don't have any matching attack
except that could be brute force
so we want epsilon of n to be meaningful
and still great even for n is equal to
constant which is what we achieved
because um even though the proof breaks
down there is no matching attack
so the big to small conjecture heuristic
is this now yes supporting proof will
break down when we have n just to be a
constant but we still get t comma
epsilon prime of n security for epsilon
prime of n approximately equal to
epsilon of n even for n greater than
constant that is the heuristic part of
it
so now we get a whole lot of options
based on
what is the definition of approximately
what is the definition of a constant
etcetera uh but the most aggressive
version of epsilon prime of n would be
something like epsilon prime of n is
equal to epsilon of n plus
the security the loss that we get uh if
we allow a brute force attack to happen
within time t
so this is the security so clearly there
could be um constructions where there is
a brute force attack that just
renders the whole thing invalid and
therefore this epsilon prime of n that
we have computed will handle will
account for this brute force attack
so the question is is this good is this
philosophy good
well the hope is yes but again we need
to be careful because it's clearly false
when we have direct product operation in
place of a cascade so say i want to
invert
s of x 1
dot x of r uh when we know that this is
t comma two to the negative r n over two
heart if n is much much bigger than log
t
but it trivially breaks down if i have n
is equal to constant because
i can bound up brute force attack
but then there is no known attack for
something like cascade or an xor uh
where the operation sort of destroys the
individual instances
right
so
general attack on cascade might also
attack aim yes
so we want
um
to design uh we also design a stream
cipher in small box crypto framework uh
we're under the under a variant of lpn
there's nothing behind the scenes but
clearly we need more validation because
we have demonstrated a possible
collision uh between the big box and
small box well but we clearly need more
validation
so let's look at
how
a stream cipher or a prg meets small box
cryptography
what we have is a function f
uh which is produces just a bit
uh it's a trivial prg especially when we
assume f is a big random model even
though it's non-expanding so let's make
it interesting for us let's make it
expanding so this is what we mean by
domain extension
so where we extend the output domain um
also known as the range right now uh to
0 1 to the l
with the following construction g of x
is f of x concatenated
0 is f of x comma 0 f of x comma 1 and f
of x comma l minus 1 all concatenated
together
the step 2 is hardness amplification
uh we know that the xor operation is
fine it's the standard thing for a prg
it's proven uh secure in the
information theoretic setting by model
at all
and in the computational setting by
notice at all
which gives us the following
construction where i have
um c inputs x 1 through x c
i apply f of x 1 comma 0 x sorted with f
of x 2 comma 0 so on and so forth f of x
c comma 0 so this is my first
bit
um this is my first bit and then i do it
for each of the l minus one remaining
bits so we at the end of the day we get
l bit output
and this is the following construction
so now let's analyze this
uh and we can do this in one go
fortunately in the idealized big box
well when we assume uh f is a random
oracle
so what we get is g tilde st comma t
comma t over n raised to the c secure
when n is 2 to the n
when capital n is 2 to the small n and
t is the number of queries to f
so when we have m n is greater than or
equal to 10 log t this is the magic
preparation step we have t comma n to
the negative point nine c security so
now we have the big to small conjecture
where this epsilon prime of t is now
introduced how to account for the brute
force search that can happen in time t
okay
but the construction that we saw before
we can also analyze it in the big box uh
world
where we can independently from big box
we get a secure length doubling prg
under the exact lpn assumption
um so so we have demonstrated a
collision we have used our recipe
of uh
domain extension hardness amplification
to construct a candidate prg we have and
we can prove it to be secure in the big
box or analysis with nothing uh no
conjecture no magic happening it's plain
and simple and we also have it analyzed
in the small box world
which brings us to the question why is
all of this relevant
why is something why is this better than
just saying hey hey yes a secure and
moving on well we use a fair bit of
proof proof and it's quite involved and
technically non-trivial
and we get bounced in a systematic way
uh there's nothing hand-waving the only
part is big to small conjecture but
again our the conjecture is actually
quite syntactically natural um and
we definitely want people to either
break or validate it um
and that is what we invite the
practitioners to do uh because on their
additions to prove uh one way or the
other theoretically and look at big to
small conjectures with a little more um
with a little bit of a magnifying glass
well let's
look at the big picture right so what we
have we need theory of hardness some for
some small components like an s-box
and the conventional models or
assumption fail
so the only thing we can do is something
like the big to small conjecture which
is a new type of assumption friendly to
small box cryptography
it's we think it's the equivalent of
one-way function from big box
cryptography
and
we introduce a new philosophy for design
and analysis what we do is we go to the
big box pro we have no way to do
anything in the small box we'll that's
big box has a lot of tools and we want
to go there
we do everything that we can prove there
and then we come back to the small box
but
we come back with the proofs
and techniques that we have in the big
box world so we don't
it's not a simple empty journey you know
the big box we come back with something
but clearly a lot of work remains
looking at five star ciphers um
looking at the big to small conjecture
itself
but
we hope that this starts off a new
uh
paradigm of cryptography
and
uh hopefully it has it's exciting enough
to uh to sort of
bring more of practice into theory and
i will see you in the real
world or well the zoom meeting where
i'll be giving the short a bridge
version of this talk and also questions
thank you